we just have to acknowledge that there
is a subset of people in the Muslim
world for whom it is true as they say of
themselves that they love death more
than we love life you have groups of
people who are offered a state who
you're not listening to they do not want
the state that they are offered they
offered a choice between a state and a
chant from the river to the sea is what
they chose I'm just saying we have to
recognize we're in a we're in a hot War
I think this is the same problem that
you're having with Trump and and other
things which is you are being invited
into the
abyss gentlemen welcome both the reason
our show works is neither Francis or I
pretend to be experts uh and we ask the
questions that are on the minds of most
people or at least we try uh I think the
people now is that we are in a moral
quandry because we simultaneously
believe many things about Israel and
Palestine that are incompatible and I'll
give you a list I don't want innocent
civilians to
die and Israel has to destroy Hamas
these two are already internally
contradictory and we can keep going
further and further into exploring that
but what I see is that the thing that is
right to say on social media to look
smart and sophisticated and balanced and
new
is Impractical it puts you in a position
where you don't know what to do um so
how do we think about this how do we
think about this issues H well I'm not
saying anything on social media that's
that's one life hack that I would
recommend um I've been looking at social
media and I've been seeing that it's um
I just think it's it's poison for us me
even the even the good parts are making
it impossible
to uh
I think I think it's making us
ungovernable like in Dem I think it's I
think it's eroding the basis of
democracy it's like even the true
information even
the the virtue of it is that it's giving
some kind of transparency that you fear
would not otherwise exist and that is
you know good for error correcting on
some level but even that in Surplus is
toxic and then there's all the
distortions of it there are the things
that performative that wouldn't be
happening in the real world but for the
fact that they're going it's going to be
broadcast on social media um I just
think it's um as I've said many places
before I think it is a kind of
psychological experiment that is
deranging US agreed and so but let's
come to Israel and Palestine because I
think that's what people want to think
about rationally how do we think about
that
issue well I
think
uh
the most obvious error that people will
make now is to imagine that body count
is the
only measure by which the the moral
balance swings right so if Israel goes
into Gaza and inadvertently kills more
people than were killed on their side
they've done they've done too much by
definition right um that's just that's
wrong in all kinds of ways but the the
the obvious way that it's wrong is that
it completely
ignores what people are actually
attempting to achieve on both sides what
kind of world they're attempting to
build what their intentions actually are
what would they do if they had more
power if if the asymmetric power in the
region were reversed how would the how
would Hamas behave Vis A Israel right um
one thing is obvious Israel
for decades if had wanted to perpetrate
a genocide against the Palestinians
could have done that on any given day
right it would have been trivi tomorrow
they could kill everyone in Gaza if they
wanted they obviously haven't wanted
that they obviously don't want to do
that now if you reverse that balance of
power and ask what would Hamas do what
would jihadist
organizations anywhere do uh they would
kill all the Jews and they and they have
told us that ad nauseum the ing Charter
of Hamas said that explicitly it look
forward to a time where where konic
prophecy would be realized when the
Earth itself would cry out against the
Jews where where the the rocks and the
trees would say oh Muslim there's a Jew
behind me come kill him right except for
one tree yeah except the one tree yes
yeah that's right um so that the the
difference in intention while people
think
intention is this is this um abstraction
intention is the software that everyone
is running inent intention is the best
predictor of what people will do if
they're given an opportunity to do it
right if they have the power to do it if
they have the technology to do it um
what will a jihadist organization do if
it gets nuclear weapons what will a
jihadist organization do if it
gets you know a a viable bioweapon right
we know the answers to these questions
these people have been telling us this
for as long as I've been alive and and
and and in isolated cases absolutely
proven to a moral certainty their
commitment to nihilism and Massacre I
mean the the Islamic State if if if you
couldn't if you knew the details of what
was happening in the Islamic State and
couldn't understand that these people
mean what they say and believe what they
say they believe then you're you're
living on another planet so anyone who's
surprised the only surprise here is
that there there was an assumption and
you know historically understandable
assumption that Hamas was not as Extreme
as Al-Qaeda or the Islamic State uh and
it certainly seems that some among them
are prepared to be that extreme so
but I mean we're we're splitting hairs I
mean jihadism is a is a
um a fairly unified concept you know
whatever the methods that whatever the
methods in the and the uh past behavior
and we just have to acknowledge that
there is a subset of people in the
Muslim world who for whom it is true as
they say of themselves that they love
death more than we love life we being
free secular people everywhere Jews
Christians Mo moderate
Muslims uh the there are people who
actually want to be martyred and have
their and see their kids martyred right
this is not they're not
bluffing they're they're perfectly
willing to die for the pleasure and
and um opportunity of killing
non-combatants intentionally killing
non-combatant so that the moral error
that people are going to make now and
they they've they're already making it
is to think that when Israel tells
people to evacuate Northern Gaza and
they don't because Hamas is telling them
not to do it or it become practically
impossible and Egypt doesn't let them
out Etc um and they drop bombs
targeting uh Hamas installations that
have been purposefully put next to
civilian areas that will cause Carnage
when when Israel bombs them like
hospitals and schools and mosques when
Israel bombs those targets and kids die
which is obviously horrible that is the
same thing
as Hamas jihadists coming in under cover
of Rocket fire at dawn and murdering
babies in their cribs it's not the same
thing and Body Count doesn't resolve
that disparity agreed so we'll come to
you in a sec Eric but joing list as a we
all but what does that mean Sam let me
let me ask you this right the United
States dropped a nuclear bomb on Japan
two of them and after
Hiroshima uh I think it was Hiroshima
not Nagasaki uh the US Army went in and
they measured the blast impact not the
release of energy from the nuclear bombs
but the actual destructive
impact and then they measured that and
said how much conventional Munitions
would we have to use to achieve the same
destructive impact in the last year and
a half of World War II the Allies the
British and the Soviets and the
Americans dropped 50 hosim as a month on
Germany we flattened it right because it
was a death cult that took over that
country and Hitler said we're going to
make a Last Stand we don't care about
civilian casualties we're going to stand
to the
death what you saying is Gaza is in the
grips of a death C of the same nature or
Worse what does that mean right I don't
want a million children in Gaza to die
and be burnt in shelters like the
Germans I don't want that and I wouldn't
defend our our um aerial bombing of of
German cities and and you know our drop
in of the bombs on Nagasaki and
Hiroshima I I think there there was a
calculation
that uh and again I'm I'm I don't
consider myself an expert on recent
scholarship on this I I know that um
about 20 years ago AC graning the
British philosopher wrote a a book about
the um specifically the the bomb the
Allied bombing of German cities and
concluded that it really was ethically
unjustifiable right that it's just we we
told ourselves a story about how
this was necessary to win the war and it
was not a compell compelling story even
at the time uh I'm not so sure what
analysis is true there but um what I
think I think Israel is held to a higher
standard than certainly we were
70 years ago and even than we you know
the British and the and the Americans
are now um I think they should hold
themselves to the highest possible
standard I mean they certainly should be
alert to the difference between
committing war crimes and following the
international law that governs how you
wage war
um I you know I think they should be
uh as reluctant as they can practice
practically be to to to kill innocent
people
and
um knowing that it's impossible not to
kill some innocent people when you're
when you're trying to fight militants in
a crowded city right especially when
those militants based on their own
completely deranged moral worldview are
committed to using their own people as
human Shields right I mean that that
disparity is um as far as the the moral
you know algebra that that can give you
insight into the difference between the
two sides that disparity says everything
to me it's like you know this is
something I recently said in my own
podcast but if you just imagine the
Israelis attempting to use their own
non-combatants as human Shields right in
any conflict against jihadist you let's
say Hezbollah comes across the northern
border and the Israelis line up with
their own women and kids you know
putting the barrels of of their weapons
on the on the shoulders of their
children thinking that Hezbollah is
going to be reluctant to shoot through
the bodies of their children to to kill
is IDF
soldiers I mean it is a completely
surreal you know Monty Python sketch
where all the Jews die it it's not it it
is laughable it is Unthinkable it's
Unthinkable at every level of it it's
Unthinkable that the that the Jews would
treat their own children and and and
non-combatants that way given what they
believe about everything and it's not
Unthinkable that they would think that
their enemies would be deterred by that
behavior
right but when you reverse it as it is
the case in in the real
world we have had to conf we all we
westerners and the Israelis have had to
confront this behavior on multiple
fronts in every conflict against
jihadists they routinely use
non-combatants as human Shields and and
Hamas is doing that now um I think
Israel has to figure out how to navigate
around that
and
eradicate jihadists you know eradicate H
Ian we're we're confounded to some
degree by our terminology here we keep
talking about terrorists and we we we
had a war on terror for you know the
quarter of a century now
um terrorism is a tactic terrorism is
not the thing we're fighting we're
fighting
Jihad and um what's the difference I'm
explain to people what the difference
well jihadism jihadism is the
the
um the radical core of Islam it is this
is this principle of holy war that can
be justified in various contexts yes
there are many many millions of Muslims
thankfully who just would who would
justify it in in ways that we would
recognize as something we could live
with right so a defensive War right a
just War you know just War Theory okay
great there are other Muslims who say no
no no you don't understand Jihad is just
an inner spiritual spiritual struggle
okay great but historically and
practically now Jihad has a component of
jihad has always been you you convert
subjugate kill the Infidel right it's
like the the Islam Islam is a religion
of Conquest it views itself as a
religion of Conquest it it expects to
win these these these contests for
believers at the you know at the end of
time and it has an exp
explicitly uh
martial ethic which
is
uh we have to win through Force right
and we're happy to Die Trying all the
however long we fail we're ultimately
going to Su succeed but we're happy to
throw our our bodies and the bodies of
our children into this because this life
is a total illusion it is has absolutely
no value this is just a a anti- room on
the on the thresholds of either heaven
or hell and the only thing that matters
is where you go after you die right and
only the True
Believers uh go go to paradise
and um if you kill them inadvertently if
you blow up a crowd of K of Muslim kids
in an attempt to kill some soldiers that
are handing out candy to them as
happened in our conflict in Iraq and
Afghanistan um there there's no Factor
the kids the the good Muslims the real
Muslims are going to Paradise they're
going to thank you right no problem um
and the bad Muslims the fake Muslims the
the infidels the the the
idolators they're going to go to hell
sooner and that's good that's an
intrinsic good that's exactly what the
creator of the universe wants um there
it's impossible to make a moral error
when you're a jihadist right if you die
it's good if your family dies it's good
if the Infidel dies it's good this is is
a death cult and we have been lying to
ourselves you know in the secular West
that there's some other logic some other
variable that explains this Behavior
it's economics it's politics these are
the assumption is that when you see
people behaving in this extraordinarily
destructive and you know Psychopathic
way they must have been pushed there by
some awful treatment that would explain
it right this must be ordinary human
rational behavior in extremis right
these people have been so tortured by
the occupation by the the apartheid
state of of Israel by the open air
prison of Gaza I mean these these
phrases that are now you know used
reflexively in the media I'm not saying
I'm not saying life in Gaza isn't
horrible I'm not saying it's not
intolerable we can talk about that but
there's a layer of this phenomenon and
this behavior that we've been living
with uh you know most clearly since
September 11th 2001 but it obviously
precedes that which is is explained only
by the religious ideology right what the
when people are doing the
unthinkable
uh again you can find so many cases
where they're doing it without grievance
right where somebody drops out of the
London School of Economics to go join
the Islamic State for the pleasure of
killing yazidis and you know raping
their women right it's just this is and
this is this was happening
you know ad nauseum right you had from a
100 countries right so this is so what
we saw Hamas do in Israel last
week is a subset it's just another
example of that same behavior yes it has
this local political
nationalistic uh struggle over territory
context but that's not the thing that
explains the
behavior um and we have to get our heads
around that we we again I'm not talking
about I'm not even talking about about
non-muslim talking about all moderate
Muslims de desperately the world waits
in desperation for moderate Muslims to
get their heads around the problem of
jihad and Eric would you agree with
Sam's assessment of the situation I
disagree first of all with Constantine
before even get to S excellent so you
know you phrase this immediately as
what's going on in Israel and
Palestine from the perspective of Hamas
do you mean it's all happening in
Palestine right so the idea is that
there's a a European occupier sitting in
Palestine you have an open air prison
people are oppressed it's completely
unlivable um and um resistance was taken
against the European
oppressor uh in Palestine so I don't
know what you're talking about so that
perspective for
example um has to do with with the
language so as soon as the frame is in
place I can tell you what the argument
is you know it's it's like looking at
different opening Tic-Tac toe moves uh
I've got all the games memorized and so
I I just don't want to even participate
as soon as I hear that
um because of these different mindsets
now to Sam's Point uh I had a big
disagreement in some sense with the way
in which the new atheists took on the
problem um of jihad and that is because
it comes out of
totalizing totalizing ideologies are
really the problem um there's a North
Korean uh totalizing ideology there's a
a Jihadi totalizing ideology sorry to
interrupt just for clarity for these
people might not know what ises
totalizing ideology mean well what I
mean in this case is that there's an
entire worldview which solves and
addresses all of your
issues um how should we structure a
family what is the purpose of life um uh
what risks may be uh assumed what when
when may one kill you have an entire
worldview that is effectively
incompatible with the outside world all
all Notions of Tolerance of coming up
with you know two people who don't
really agree but agree enough in order
to serve each other coffee maybe marry
into each other's families you know
whatnot um there is a sort
of way in which you're you're open
through moderation and through tolerance
to the points of view of others within a
relatively broad but still restricted
Spectrum this is outside of that
Spectrum
so the the issue is not Islam to me the
issue is totalizing ideologies that
provide all answers and there aren't
that many of them left right like Soviet
communism died off it was a totalizing
ideology um you see the art the music
the the cinema you can you can spend
your entire life in a Soviet mindset um
based on what was produced during that
period um but not to not all totalizing
ideologies are the same no they are
right so it's like the Cru the martyrdom
completely changes the game theory right
like like if if if Putin was a martyr we
would feel differently about war Ukraine
I promise but I'm just trying to account
for let me drag you
there so
the first problem I have is that
totalizing
ideologies are dangerous because there's
no way from outside MH to check them yes
so if there's an error then you end up
with whatever that area is you know to
the 10,000 power now when you drop in
this as a
strategy uh the next reason I can't
really respond to what got said is that
the the language again that we use like
both sides oh so what about
Christian uh Arabs you know somehow
they're not part of
the uh Islamic Jihad or Hamas but on the
other hand they may have sympathies with
it or on the other hand they may
secretly hate it and say how can we
can't get better representation some of
them may Pine to live in
Israel um as you know I lived in Israel
for 2 years and I had sorts of crazy
conversations and the spectrum of Arab
perspectives or Drew perspectives or you
know it's a much richer place and I
worry already about the both sides in
because it it ain't both sides it's so
many different factions and then in
order to get at this because the Israeli
government will have to take action
against the Hamas government right and
so that is a both sides so let's talk
about that because you're arguing with
the frame so give us the frame the way
that you think the frame should be well
my my my first comment is is that you're
going to use words like Palestinians
you're going to use words like
occupation occupied territories somebody
else might use Judean Samaria somebody
else might say
Palestine as soon as I know the language
I know what the arguments are going to
be okay this is not my language and I
don't believe these things and I've
agreed to be more or less silent
uh on a bunch of things while there was
a peace process because peace processes
are are about BS to a certain extent you
have to lie through a peace process in
order to get something at the end of it
and that failed so you know the first
thing I'm going to say is I don't
believe that this is an a an occupied
people I don't believe that the Arabs
are under occupation and that's going to
sound crazy because you're not exposed
to any perspective that sounds like that
so how how are could you ever come to
that
conclusion you have groups of people who
are offered a state who we are not
listening to they do not want the state
that they are offered they are offered a
choice between a state and a
chant and if you know the chant it's
from the river to the sea from the river
to the sea is what they chose you could
have a state or you could have a
chant and they want the chant they are
the tip of the
spear in the global battle against
Western hegemony against an occupying
European power in holy Arab
land and they're not going to give up
on that as a collective political entity
for a
relatively
modest prosperous State Trading with it
with the occupi
with you know joint economics joint
faint that's very troubling to us
because we have this idea of why
wouldn't you want a state you could have
a state you could be prosperous you
could send your kids to Purdue you
know and
that's that's not easy for us this is
basically if you think about
motherhood you don't think about monism
by
proxy right now what do you de with a
deal what do you do when you have a
mother who comes to the hospital
hospital with a child is continuously
getting sick you know and getting
harmed you
know you have to ask well is it possible
that the mother is harming the child so
you're about to
see Tiny children pulled out of rubble
in Northern Gaza you're going to see it
add nausey you're going to see people
rushing to the hospital you're going to
see mothers wailing so we can talk about
the whole thing about about the
martyrdom and how everybody prays that
their family will be martyred and you
know what sometimes it's true sometimes
you see on camera somebody saying thank
God they took my son you know blah blah
blah but those are actually much more
complicated things sometimes you turn
the camera off and the person is crying
because they know what they're supposed
to say and and they know what they're
actually feeling so my my problem with
this is
that this is so much more complicated
than the than the discussion we're
pre-programmed to have that is
guaranteed to fail the richness of this
problem where Hamas is effectively the
mother in a monaz and by proxy situation
right and the children in you damn
straight you're going to be pulling
babies out of that Rubble because that's
what Hamas wants and Israel cannot
figure out how to extricate herself from
this Dance of
Death well that's why we're here that's
what we're talking about right so what
I'm trying to say is you don't get out
of this you have a very unconventional
foe in Hamas and in and in totalitarian
Islam and and in Jihad and and in Isis
and Al-Qaeda and for some reason
mainstream
media refuses to show us the images that
they showed us during the Vietnam War
through mainstream Outlets if you saw
what I've
seen if if you if you
watched the Hamas videos the Isis videos
the
if you read de beak if you did any of
this
stuff you'd be sick to your stomach
you'd be a changed
person and we don't have that I remember
that the night my parents turned off the
TV during the Vietnam war one of my
earliest memories I believe it was gi's
heads on Pikes carried by the north the
Vietcong you're you're watching American
severed heads on sticks if you think
about all the pets are prize winning
photographs from the Vietnam era right
you're watching a monk burn to death
you're watching a street
execution right to the head you're
watching naked children with their
children with their clothes burned off
from
Napal you didn't see falling man the
most famous picture from 9911 was
basically not shown in the United States
there is this layer that is determined
to push a fiction to us which is a
transparent fiction
about the General nature of Islam Islam
is complicated you have to study it
there multiple schools of thought Beyond
Shia versus Sunni versus amadi you know
you you could just in Sunni Islam
different schools of jurus prudence
which lead to totally radically
different outcomes between the salafists
and the hanafi
adherence and what we've done is we've
come up with this ve this childlike
concept of an oppressed people and a
religion of peace and all of the stuff
is is unworkable and it's all mind
control and it's all propaganda and what
my feeling is again is I don't want to
start the conversation from where I
think you guys want to start it from I
want to start from the fact that none of
us are prepared to have this
conversation because we haven't been
exposed to it we don't know what the
real issues are and if we take the terms
that are handed to
us we if we have the best and most
intellectual conversation it will still
be completely morally defined let me
just disagree with the the general
thrust of what you said there because
much of what you said is true but
doesn't
actually confound the the argument that
I'm making which is that all of that
complexity is true there's the
complexity of Islam it's this variegated
culture you know and it interacts with
cultural uh contingencies that have
nothing to do with religion right so
even there things that we would object
to under Islam like you know female
genital mutilation which
um doesn't have a direct direct really
direct connection to to theology right
and yet it's correlated with with with
the Muslim world but it's not exclusive
to the Muslim World etc etc it's all
this hair splitting we can do but there
is a very simple core to this right the
concept of jihad the concept of
martyrdom the the the the very clear
totalizing death cult I get it yeah
death to apostates right all the this is
this is the clearest piece of code this
is like you know eight lines of code
that every time you run them produce the
same it's the clearest piece of Co same
it's the fact that it has no repressor
bound to it to borrow a metaphor from
DNA and so in the in Deuteronomy we have
repressor bound to Bad Code so the code
doesn't run the problem is is that all
the safeties are off the gun you've got
promoter rather than repressor for some
collection of people for some other
collection explain that in a different
way sure it's too complicated it's not
that complicated it's not that
complicated for you but it's too
complicated for me to understand and
therefore for a lot of people watching
so explain it simp
templ okay we have code in deuteron a
lot of the bad code in Islam comes from
Judaism so Christianity and Islam are
two of our most popular off shets MH and
bad code has an inheritance property
that sometimes it permeates through the
system if everybody agrees that the Old
Testament is important right in
Deuteronomy I believe there's a passage
by the way what you said before about it
being konic I believe you were actually
referencing a Hadith I don't know if
that's accurate about the yeah yeah so I
want to be clear about in Deuteronomy
there's a passage that says for example
if somebody says let's go worship uh
God's unknown to our fathers set upon
him with a stone m I don't think there's
any record of Jews
stoning uh an apostate an Prost
apostatizing
apostate however how you get that code
not to run is that you come up with some
justification for example oh too bad
about the second temple being destroyed
if we don't have the second temple then
we can't convene the S hedrin if the
religious courts aren't enforced then
who who decides whether this is just and
unjust so unfortunately the code can't
run so we have got bad
code that doesn't get run because it's
blocked from running yep and quite
honestly in many places in the world
you've got bad code that is blocked from
running and so I don't want to have a
conversation about you can read it right
in the text it's true you can read it
right in the text but you have to think
about the epigenetics what is that
determines does this code run or is this
code blocked so the problem is you have
got a totalizing death cult with all the
safeties off the
gun for some subset of people and then
we're going to have this conversation
about are we going to be fastidiously
accurate in which case it'll take 17
hours and nobody will want to watch it
or is somebody going to say you know do
the conservative thing to say well
there's some something's going wrong
with Islam and then you've got all the
the collateral damage of reasonable
normal people who are you know a vice
president for inventory at some company
uh who happens to go to the mosque and
he's thinking like what does this have
to do with me and then you have got the
weird issues about the sympathies where
you've got sympathies for completely
insane positions from completely
moderate people including now
generically college students college
students are up for people firing
automatic weapons and Deport aties
having no idea who's inside is a mother
you know nursing a child inside the port
a body who cares and to say I stand with
Palestine and show a hang glider for
black lives matter think about all the
black lives matter signs I throughout
the entire George Floyd thing I was
saying don't support black lives matter
now black lives matter was a piece of
Genius called declarative marketing I
don't know if you've ever heard it so we
had products in the 70s called G your
hair smells terrific or I Can't Believe
It's Not Butter was the name of the
product so the name of the product is
called black lives matter mhm how can
you disagree with that you know so save
save the adorable puppy dogs is what I
would call a terrorist organization if I
had to um because how can you disagree
with save the adorable puppy dogs we're
deranged by language we're not watching
things in mainstream context that would
make us sick to our stomachs and we are
becoming infused with a radical ideology
through the Democratic party that is as
if it was liberalism adjacent like
you've got radical left-wing death cults
that want Revolution for the oppressed
that have a seat at the Democratic table
at the same time that somebody like Sam
or myself uh traditionally a Democrat is
completely unwelcome and you know my my
claim is is that you're seeing an echo
of this madness of jihadism inside
mainstream American campuses and there's
one thing that I would like to add as
well is that my grandfather was an Arab
my grandfather was Venezuelan but he
originated from Lebanon his surname was
Saud
and he was Coptic Christian and I he was
a doctor and when he retired he became a
historian and he's his books won
prizes in his third language and we went
to Israel on holiday now I'm a Catholic
all our family a Catholic and they said
to my grandfather we said to my
grandfather would you like to come to
Israel with us bear in mind this is an
historian this is a learned man and he
said as long as I live I will never set
foot on Israeli soil I will never put
money in an Israeli pocket and I think
the the other aspect to this
conversation that we're not addressing
is the hatred that exists on both sides
and we misuse that word hatred a lot I
hate peanuts I hate the opposition
football team this is hatred to its core
and what do you do with two groups of
people some of whom hate each other in
its truest sense can you resolve
that it's worse than hatred and it's
it's simpler than than Eric you're
making it out it's it's not I granted
there's a there's a ton of complexity
but the
complexity isn't the main problem here
right so it's worse than hatred in that
and again I I really do think this is a
a failure of empathy on the part of SE
secular rational people they just can't
get their heads around what it would be
like to actually believe in Paradise
right they they've never met they they
at most they've met people who pretend
to believe in Paradise um they just
don't know
what true belief is like and therefore
they don't they can't kind of
sympathetically run this particular
piece of code and see its perfectly
rational implications I mean what would
how would you live if you believed that
there was nothing more important than
Waging War for the one true faith and
dying in the process the only straight
path to Paradise was to to be martyred
right the it's the only thing that
bypasses the resurrection and all of the
uncertainty of whether you're going to
get there it's just this is it's just
like you're just whisked past the Velvet
Rope and you're you're you're in the
bottle room with God waiting for your
friends and family to arrive right
um people
can't understand what it would be like
to actually believe this and so they and
and so they think there must be some
other motive so when you read issue of
dbek right you know the Islamic State's
highly professional newsletter or
magazine great production quality it's
uh it was shockingly good I mean that's
when I commented on it it was it was it
was actually a very bad sign that it was
as well written and as well copy eded
stuff it was a no because it show shows
you the quality of people they were
recruiting from from Europe mostly
um but
it's and I and I I I disagree with the
the the analogy the the epigenetic
genetics analogy ran because it's
there's not this is a much shorter piece
of code the kran it's a much more
unified uh code I mean the the Quran
there's there's much less
self-contradiction in the Quran than
than you find in the Bible right I mean
the Bible is the Bible simply does not
present a unified message and it's very
easy to pick and choose and especially
if you're a Christian you wind up with
with Jesus and his in his better moods
and you could you could live a
completely benign pacifist sort of life
or you could
be you know a religious lunatic who's
who's dangerous and divisive you can
sort of have it however you want to have
it it is much harder under Islam it's
not to say this impossible and and and
as I said earlier Islam is much better
designed they they absolutely need to
find their repressor Hardware to figure
out how to how to make Jihad just a
matter of just war and just War Theory
you know uh as you know the Christians
have it more or less and and um and
spiritual struggle that would be great
they have to figure out how to do it
it's damn hard to do it especially when
you look at the example of the Prophet
Muhammad who's not a guy who got
crucified and told everyone to wait for
the end of the world he was a conquering
warlord I mean it's like having gangas
Khan as your as your savior I mean it's
just it's just not a Islam is much
better designed Sam for jih for holy war
and for for Endless conflict it's it's
not a morally normative
observation it had the opportunity to
look at Orthodox Judaism or
Judaism and
Christianity and it became a piece of
code that is incredibly difficult to
deal with even down to the engineering
of um of a priority of operations so I
forget how it works that you have the
what of the chapters the suras yeah
yeah the ones that abrogate the other
ones yes but the more
contradictions but you also have an
order of operation so as a piece of
design we can
Marvel uh at Islam but you still have
two very different Traditions one
clerical one more akin to protestantism
of a direct relationship to the code in
the in Sunni Islam you do have multiple
schools of jurist Prudential thought
what I'm trying to get at is you became
fixated on the fact that
normal ordinary Americans median
Americans cannot figure out how to talk
about the problems that come out of
totalitarian Jihadi ideology well well
worse than that is to the point you just
raised about what's happening on college
campuses we've got we've got the most
privileged and ostensibly well-educated
people in our society students right now
today at Harvard and Stanford who were
signing open letters in support of the
murder of infants in their cribs because
who are in support of message killing
let's be very specific it's not murder
and it's not the number message killing
is different than regular killing
message killing is when you engage in an
act and you make it cinematic and you
make it hurt you make it psychologically
so disturbing that you
amplify power of each death right Sadam
was a an incredible um practitioner of
message killing when you think about uh
Luca brzi you know in The Godfather
showing up uh with a vest with a fish in
it nobody knows how to read the message
um you have kids on college campuses who
are supportive of message killing and
you think about how do you deliver the
maximal amount of pain to a
father but these are the same people who
are who are winging about
microaggressions and they need safe
spaces they need trigger warnings they
think words are violence I mean no they
don't they don't think any of that same
there was no woke ideology you could not
tie your shoes if you imbibed wokeism
it's such a
contradictory collection of things that
don't make sense Michael M said on our
Show recently something that I think is
not untrue which is that these people
don't use language to communicate they
use it to manipulate that's right right
however one of the things that always
worries me about our space is we
critique others and we don't model and
we don't talk about how to think and
I've asked we spent 40 minutes I've
asked both of you how to think about
this issue we nowhere near there so
let's try you both put some ideas
forward about how you see this problem
how do we think about this H how if
you're right let's just for the sake of
argument this is all about jihadism I
have an answer for you but I let me
preface it by saying that one I'm not an
expert in any of the relevant areas that
will give confidence in this answer this
is the Internet it's never stopped
anyone so I'm not like so I'm I'm you
been on Twitter
yeah not much
recently um so I'm I'm very happy that
I'm not in charge here like so like so I
can say I can say this knowing that I
have absolutely no responsibility to
actually make this kind of decision
but I what I think we in the W in this
in the west however you want to conceive
it um should do is
recognize that we are perpetually at war
with aspiring Martyrs right we're at war
with jihadis now how many people like
fitting that description actually exist
in the Muslim
world is as yet undetermined right but
it's um more than we should be
comfortable with and it's and and still
most Muslims do not fit that description
obviously right and then there are kind
of concentric circles of of decreasing
support for the the the um the project
of jihad but we have to recognize that
we're at war with
jihadism it's and in whatever guys
whatever organization or not or non
organization it exists in
um and we should and we should be
killing jihadis right that we're not
going to negotiate with jihadis we're
not going to live peaceful peacefully
with jihadis um when you raise your hand
and you say I'm a Jihadi that should
make your life much more dangerous
officially from the point of view of of
the
Israelis the CIA anyone anyone who's
part of this project um but then we're
back to
Dresden this is why I brought it up I
think this mostly should be covert I
think this I don't think we need to take
credit for this I don't think the
Israelis should say we we dealt with a
problem over here and the the US should
say
clandestine what how are you
distinguishing those clandestine means
secret covert means
deniable um I'm not sure I understand
all that you're when the CIA undertakes
a covert operation yeah the idea that it
if discovered it will be denied and that
the links to the sponsor will be severed
so that it cannot be traced back to the
CIA so in other words
it's a pretty big distinction I just
didn't know whether you were yeah no I
don't actually I don't know I don't know
if it's important in this case but um
this is this is this this is an idea
that doesn't originate with me I think I
first encountered this with
um the war correspondent uh and
journalist Robert Kaplan
maybe I think it might might even be
before 911 he he wrote on this um but
just the idea that we need to that all
of this has to be public all of this has
to be demonstrative all all this all of
this has to be framed by
speeches uh that we need to declare
we're going to go to war in Iraq right
you know we're going to go to war in
Afghanistan
um I mean if any if my thinking about
anything has changed since
911 the I mean I was never I was never a
supporter of the war in Iraq I was never
a Critic of the war in Iraq I never knew
what to think about the war in Iraq
except I noticed that it was it seemed
like a catastrophic distraction from the
war in Afghanistan which I absolutely
did support um and which was you know a
helpless fail failure it certainly
seems um but so if my thinking has
changed about anything is this the idea
that we can do this project of nation
building that like by analogy with what
we did with you know post World War II
with Germany and Japan which are are
miracles of of uh Resurrection really I
mean look at look at the enemies we had
in Germany and Japan and look at the
state of the world now right it's just
the idea that they are our friends and
collaborators and have been for for
virtually for as long as you know we've
been alive um it's an amazing reboot of
civilization after you know it's near
destruction um the idea that we can
accomplish that in the Middle East and
accomplish that in a Muslim culture just
because we think everyone must want
freedom on some level and must you know
must want to run the same Democratic
code as we do and you know dye their
fingers and say they voted um I'm much
more pessimistic about that project ever
being fulfill in the lifetime of anyone
hearing this um than I was and so I
think we should be very circumspect
about owning anything because the other
thing is that because all of this is
seen through religious lens on the other
side and it's all a matter of sanctities
and their their trespass as far as the
IE can see so so you bring in Infidel
troops even with the best of intentions
to do anything good and it's a s it's a
Sac sacrilege worthy of the murder of
non-combatant right so many people
subscribe to this worldview Beyond just
jihadists that you just
can't the project is over with the best
of intentions even before it starts so I
I think again this is and I I say this
is someone who um doesn't know all that
I'm getting wrong here at least
pragmatically like I don't know I don't
in terms of Co covert or clandestine
operations how you go about killing
jihadists wherever they exist um you
know we should get as good as we can get
at that we should get as good as we can
get at that and so like so the leaders
of Hamas in Qatar yeah those those guy
the clock should be ticking on those
guys it is yeah so but that's so that's
the most important piece from my point
of view
Jihad as a job description jihadism has
to be f but these people aren't cowards
these people who organize this expect to
die so one of the things that we say we
should FF that cow cowardly it's not
true I would I would never say no one no
one has said that ER let's stop with
stuff as the old joke goes Sam you know
what's the difference between a moderate
Muslim and a
Jihadi um the harassment of his sister
at an Israeli checkpoint you know the
problem is you can't just go around
killing jihadis because a lot of people
Express support for Jihad who going to
pick up a gun or
STP that's a distinction I'm making I
mean there are people
who in term the other very depressing
thing is that if we and we have poll
results going back now decades when you
ask Muslim communities not just in the
Muslim world but in the west you what's
your level of support for suicide
bombing in defense of Islam right the
numbers are awful right and
so that's not what I'm I'm talking about
the people who are actually deciding to
be jihadis you they're going to they're
going to get up tomorrow morning to and
their goal their job is how do I kill
INF Islam start what was that when did
suicide bombing and Islam start this is
not we don't have to talk about the Tam
Tigers it's not tactic the Beirut
barracks right so we're talking about a
relatively recent phenomenon yeah but
bombs are a relatively recent there was
the Golden Age of of hijacking before
that I'm not I'm not making any excuses
for it I'm trying to say that you're
talking about something of such
consequence
the idea that we should if I take covert
that we should have a an official policy
of trying to identify people who are
Jihadi whatever that means which is very
complicated they identify themselves
right they they they literally
move I had a friend in Cambridge
Massachusetts who you would have
identified as a Jihadi and he said to me
once you go to Israel we will never be
friends again we will never speak uh I
will have to hate you blah blah blah
blah BL blah he was the one who told me
about the Hadith with he says you know
remember that this is the tree that is
the tree of the Jews that will hide you
when the earth cries for your
blood it's an incredible mindset and you
and I are Allied on that it's a mindset
that Americans have difficulty thinking
through but what you're talking about
when you talk about the decision
boundary of which jihadis to kill yes so
air on the side of conservative right
I'm just saying we have to recognize
we're in a we're in a hot War I think
this the same problem that you're having
with Trump and and other things which is
you are being invited into the
abyss okay you're not you're not
understanding hold but wait let me just
clarify what I'm recommending here
because if you're not understanding it
the audience isn't understanding it what
I'm saying is much more conservative at
least in my view with respect to
Collateral Damage and and the and the
ethics of of warfare than what is likely
to be happening certainly what's what
what I think is likely to happen in Gaza
right I think we should the you want a
lot of targeted surgical stuff two
things first of all let's let Sam finish
and the second thing is Eric I want to
hear a positive proposition from you
because you're kind of positioning
yourself in a critique place from which
it's much easier to operate so let Sam
finish his point and then I want to hear
from you what you think we should do
because otherwise it's kind of
asymmetrical so go Sam so our progress
morally as a
civilization you especially in the West
a global civilization but but especially
in the west has
been on many fronts but one crucial
front is that we have become more and
more
uncomfortable in taking innocent life
however
defensively when we wage war right so so
collateral damage is it's that phrase is
a euphemism that hides just these the
the
gassiest outcomes where you have you
know
children orphaned and children blown up
and every permutation of that that
horror and we because we've become more
and more transparent to ourselves in how
we wage war we are increasingly less and
less capable of Waging War the way we
did in in World War II and and and
Vietnam and and I think that's that's a
good thing it's a good thing until it
isn't right I me I can imagine us
getting into a war where we have to
finally say
[__] it we we have to we have to roll
back our moral compass to 1945 because
this enemy is hiding behind so many
beautiful blond-haired little girls all
those girls are going to die otherwise
we all die right so like that's that's
conceivable to me but we I certainly
hope we don't have a future like that
and so I think we should have a bias
toward being more and more compassionate
more and more scrupulous more and more
aware of how how intolerable it is for
in this case completely innocent
families in Gaza to have 500 lb bombs
dropped on their heads right it's just
it's it's completely unacceptable the
details are unacceptable and I I don't
share your view that if we just saw more
of the imagery that would help us
calibrate here because the imagery is so
provocative the imagery of a dead baby
being being pulled out of rubble is so
provocative it's impossible to think
about what should happen in the world on
the basis of that data point right that
doesn't guide you that just confounds
you um and so I think what I'm what I
what I'm arguing for and again I don't
understand the practicalities of this I
mean we need to bring in you know Delta
Force and the CIA and people who
actually know how you do things on that
front to to know what's possible but I
think yes anyone who joins a jihadist
organization who's in the business of
waging Jihad right then that should be a
death sentence that should be that
should be suicide right we should figure
out how to make that within the within
the the the the possibilities here we
should figure out how to make that so
and I mean we have our friend Douglas
Murray who you know we both love and
who's who's incredibly courageous and
wise on on this particular front um he's
walking around saying that anyone who
supports amas right even just anyone who
gets out on the sidewalk and and and
stands on one of these signs um as they
have in in uh this week uh supporting
what happened in in Israel those people
should lose their citizenship and
be evicted from the UK right I try to
map that onto your free speech concerns
in the US how how practical is that how
ethical My Free Speech concerns well
just so you know guys Hamas is a
prescribed terrorist organization in the
UK therefore to express support for it
is a crime okay so but but like try to
map that onto the American context right
we've got we've got Stanford students
who are effectively those people right
not only are we kicking them out of
Stanford which I could sort of support I
mean there's more to talk about there
but like yeah I mean there's a certain
form of cancel culture that that would
uh make some sense to me at this moment
but on Douglas's account we should just
send them to Gaza right just drop them
in Gaza and say good luck this is what
this is what you wanted this is your
worldview um
okay that's an when you're talking about
extreme derangements of our civil
society and our politics and our
our way of life and and and Boundary
problems how do we like like just what
sort of what constitutes support for
Hamas in in these last seven days right
on social media and and on the quad uh
it's an impossible problem so you can be
as judicious as you want to be I just
and I and I would Advocate that but I
think we have to recognize
euphemisms asde that the terrorism is
not our problem jihadism is our problem
and it's not that we it's not that we
don't have other problems North Korea is
also a problem the to other totalizing
dogmas are also a problem this is a very
specific problem that is not going away
it will be with us for as long as we're
alive and as long as our kids are alive
great so Eric what is your vision for
how we
start my positive Vision so that okay
look because you asked for it I think in
all of the appearances I've never
actually shared this publicly um but
you're forcing the issue and I'm not
hiding from it it's
just if we don't do anything different
we we're going to get what Hamas wanted
so the first of all I mean the level of
disagreement is very weird because it's
100% agreement on all sorts of factual
things that you and I agree on um but no
the the pictures really do matter
because when you pull a baby out of the
rubble the key question is is that
Rubble due to Hamas or is that Rubble do
to the person who dropped the bomb right
so we have this concept of suicide by
cop you're about to see suicide by cop
or infanticide by cop or monk hasm by
proxy via cop where the cop is the IDF
agreed okay if you want a positive
Vision the Baseline is Israel is going
to flatten North Gaza and there's going
to be tons of death and destruction and
I want I would love to stop it the right
thing to have done in my opinion which
will not be popular which will be much
more hated by Arabs than what I than the
idea of killing uh families uh through
collateral damage is very
simple I know I know where you're going
I I think I've read your mind but go
ahead
yeah Israel has a claim on a lot of land
that it
controls and the Arabs have a claim on
the same land there two competing claims
if you take the Israeli claim you say
look This Land Is Ours but we are not
pigs and we are not so attached to this
land and we're not so blind to your
needs that we would not give you a
portion of land that we consider to be
ours because it comes from our tradition
we have a schedule if you want to live
as brothers in peace you know there
arguments Between Brothers and families
but if you want a prosperous
State you go this many days without
any loss of life due to Terror Jihad or
any of these things and we will seed
this land to your future state so that
there guaranteed that there will be a
Palestine even though we consider the
land to be
ours you're interested in rape here's
how
many acres we will
Annex you interested in Murder you're
interested in blowing up families you
want to take an egged bus over a cliff
whatever it is is that you're thinking
about here's the schedule of the acreage
that you will lose we will have an
annexing ceremony and we will name it
after your
victims whatever Town whatever
settlement that we're going to put in
that and it'll be permanently a part of
Israel and so that way when you do
something to us where you're begging us
to kill you and your children to blow up
your buildings to bulldoze your houses
we're not going to fall for it anymore
what we're going to do is we're going to
have a ribbon cutting
ceremony and what we're going to see is
a large and larger and larger state of
Israel as your moronic death cult
continues to grind against innocent life
so rather than have a single death
you're going to have a transfer of
acreage okay but that entails a lot of
death you're taking that acreage with
tanks because every
time first of all there's a lot of land
that Israel already controls that
doesn't need to be taken by a tank you
have a different situation in God Gaza
in particular right so Gaza first of all
was is not occupied it was given mhm mhm
it's controlled in terms of its borders
but when you make videos showing how oh
look you know we dug up all these pipes
we figured out how to get over the fence
with paragliders etc etc you understand
now why uh the borders are being
controlled so yes there's a certain
amount that you have to do but you can
certainly minimize this if suddenly a
giant chunk of land disappeared
from the West Bank and that was the
response and nobody died for example but
how there there people on that land I
mean how how does nobody die well first
of all people have been transferred from
Land second of all there are junks of
land you know there are settlements and
things that have not yet been formally
annexed to
Israel I'm what I'm trying to say Sam is
that you're speaking to somebody who
speaks only the language of violence and
the the thing that I don't know how to
communicate is I have a rule that I
can't care about somebody else's
children more than they care about their
children they speak a different they
speak a there's even a more important
language which is the Lang language of
religious symbols this is where I
thought you were going I was it turns
out telepathy isn't
real because um no actually I was going
there but I saw what you were doing they
care much more about buildings than
about their children right I mean if you
really want to see the wheels come off
Israel could say listen return the
hostages in 48 hours or we blow up the
Dome of the Rock right and they just rig
that building to explode what do you
think happens the entire world lights up
right I mean like we're talking about
it's like that's that's Armageddon right
over a
building right this is it's completely
crazy it's all upside down the ethics of
this are completely upside down you
don't mean buildings because there are
plenty of apartment buildings where
Hamas has you know headquarters and
builds Rockets I'm talking about the
Dome of the Rock yeah yeah yeah
so but like if you can talk about
emotional leverage that's the point of
emotional leverage that's that's more
than we're going to kill all your kids
that we're going to kill this one empty
building right sorry I don't know where
we are exactly I'm just saying that that
like that that is if you're talking
about this this is where I thought you
were going but that that Israel Israel
does not have leverage saying we're
we're going to go back and take Gaza for
ourselves or we're going to take more of
the West Bank that's not Leverage the
the whole place is as big as his living
room it's it's a tiny Sam if you Annex
land to
Israel I guarantee you the world will
freak out it won't freak out as if you
threatened Alexa and I don't even want
to talk about this because I don't want
to get
in invol I'm not saying I recommend that
I'm saying that is that is how upside
down the situation is that would be the
most provocative thing they could
possibly do that's that's actually under
their control let's interrogate this
idea of annexing land because I I think
Sam criticism that I hear Sam's critique
rather that I hear and agree with is
that if you start annexing land you are
going to have to do it by force which is
when you're back to square one Israel is
the occupi state flattening cities
killing babies Etc how is that different
to where we are
now I'm trying to say that in the cycle
of violence what is sought by The
Architects of murder misery and horror
is reprisal physical kinetic reprisal
I'm saying deny them that but you're not
going to deny them that you're going to
make them the jihadis if we accept that
they exist which of course they do they
are going to Scupper that process with
everything they have by they do and some
that you're and then you're going to
have to Annex land on which Palestinians
live in which case you're back to
Collateral Damage again look you've got
a terrible situation okay we all agree
I'm not coming up with this
as this is what to do when you have two
normal foes that are in dispute over
mineral resources we know what that is
this is not that this
is I want please flatten our our
apartment buildings so that we can pull
the babies from the rubble we have the
we have the cameras and we know how to
do this in 4k right this is a completely
different sort of an enemy and my claim
is
the story of Israel exercising
power over Arabs who are not Israeli
citizens is a cancerous
story and if Israel does not figure out
how to get out of that story even to the
point where it's got a state that it has
to go up against in a war and I agree
with Sam that we fetishize now a level
of morality due to professional um um
military uh ethics that is probably
unsustainable in actual war between
between comparable Rivals we're going to
have to get a lot less squeamish people
are going to die this is what happens in
war there's always collateral damage
and the situation that I want and you
know again I this isn't particularly
good for this this 50th Anniversary
attack of the Yom kapor War I wanted
this in place 20 years ago nobody would
listen and that was you know based much
more around blowing up a pizza parlor
you know okay great so there's land that
we've always thought was ours and we're
going to formally take it and we're not
going to have a reprisal we're not going
to have a a a bulldozer knock over a
house because Israel is being induced
into a game theory according to the
local rules of the Middle East and then
broadcast into a somewhat anti-semitic
West um this is the strategy of the
Arabs in this situation which is how to
get Israel to play by local rules of the
Middle East for exports into a
sophisticated uh somewhat you know
mildly anti-semitic West uh for people
particularly on the left who uh don't
particularly like Jews uh and um want to
be engaged in some sort of um
recapitulation of the Civil Rights era
or sou South African apart time I agree
with that 100% but that does not mean
that the solution you proposed works and
that's the thing that we're talking
about we just have to imagine what
happens when you grab all that land then
where then Israel just has different
borders but there's still at war with
jihadists and and H going to be war with
jihadists forever Sam that's not going
to end and and to be honest and I can't
believe we're not pushing back on this
the idea of killing people with
sympathies with Jihadi ideology I
said jihadists yeah not sympathy
sympathy for jihadist and you if I join
a Jihadi organization does that make me
a Jihad well well I mean depends we've
killed Majid let's let's let's make it
clear no he wasn't I mean he wasn't a
that wasn't a jihadist organization he
wasn't a Jihadi no
okay um I mean so the book I I wrote
with Maj based on this you know verbal
debate we had the Islam and the future
of Tolerance is there to be seen and
Majid makes uh lots of interesting
distinctions between jihadists Islam
jihadists are a subset of islamists but
they're also revolutionary islamists who
don't who aren't you know signing up to
be suicide bombers and there's also
islamists who are not inclined to use
violence they're inclined to use the
Democratic process in order to to impose
Sharia law but it's but it's they're
very patient and it's they they don't
support al- Qaeda and they don't support
Isis Etc uh and then there are
conservative Muslims who don't support
any of that but they're still way more
conservative than you'd want them to be
when you're talking about things like
honor killing or the rights of women or
Etc so lot to talk about I'm talking
about the people who are committed to
waging Jihad who's like that's the
that's their gig now right no if if the
idea is that there's a bright line which
is that you own multiple suicide vests
you know or even though you've never put
one on but you're you're certainly you
know but like but like the yeah the
leaders of Hamas who were who were just
sitting and could talk right now right
like
that long natural lives ahead of them I
I I I certainly hope not right but like
but that's the the front line for me is
there it's
not I I I already assume those people
are know that they're going to die at
Israeli things yeah well I don't know I
mean we we have a non assassination
policy right in we we the US well yeah
yeah I mean Democratic societies
generally would say that has a non-
assassination polic no no no I'm I'm not
but
but it would be disavowed it's anathema
given our our current again I'm not even
I'm not even sure I know the rules of
war that that would govern Israel now
but um you need a military lawyer to to
talk about the details here what I'm
saying is
that we should recognize who the enemy
actually is and what the problem
actually is and it's not that
it it's a matter of people with
understandable rational grievances
who've just been push too far and if you
could only cater to their their is going
to be killed yeah well so but that that
would be a good thing right nobody's
arguing
that there are jihadists in a hundred
countries right I understand that so I'm
trying to figure out this idea whether
the CIA or the mad because those are two
very different organizations that work
together they should be unified on this
front we should recognize that
jihadism is a non-starter for the future
of of a a global civilization assume
that the people in our covert agencies
already know
that well I I don't know if that's a
safe assumption but that but that would
be do you remember the Abu Dhabi I think
it was Abu Dhabi video the guy checks
into a hotel and then all the Israeli
teams descend and they track all of them
in and all of them out okay but given
the failure of the IDF to
to not even prevent even respond to what
happened last week I mean get me it's
just what do you mean failure to respond
hasn't happened yet no no what happened
for in the first 24 hours what did you
expect what was I everyone was expecting
a better no one was expecting people to
be hiding in their houses for 24 hours
begging to be rescued by an IDF that
didn't seem not to exist right I mean
this is this is colossal it's a colossal
intelligence failure it's a it's a
failure to put to even know what's
happening at the border it's a failure
to respond to an emergency once it once
it was you know how degraded Israel is
okay but that's that's my point well so
you're asking me to assume that the mad
and the CIA have this well in this
assassination program that I'm wishing
for for Christmas well- in hand I can't
make that I can't make that assumption
when when you have a 1500 jihadis come
across the to let each other talk and
and there's no response right because
everyone you know because it's Shabbat
and everyone's doing something doing
something else right it's it's it's um I
don't think we can take for granted that
we have this problem that that that
enough people understand what the
problem actually is because there's so
many euphemisms and so much political
correctness and so much Multicultural
[__] confounding a very clear
discrimination of that relates to the
power of specific ideas right you get
one issue of dbek you should understand
who the enemy is right and um in my in
my but in my experience in talking to
people especially you know overeducated
academics you know you talk to an
anthropologist about this you just get a
wall of of confusion right um
so hopefully again I don't know I don't
know how
clear anyone's thinking is
when in the immediate aftermath
of women of young women being being
raped and stolen and as hostages from a
peace Rave you have their Co their
counterparts at Harvard and
Stanford celebrating it right like so
so I just I don't think we can assume
people know what the hell is going on
and and and what they should be
motivated to pay attention to now and so
that's why if conversations like this
have any value sure it's in clarifying
those those variables one thing that I
wanted to touch on very quickly is you
said something very interesting which is
do you know how degraded Israel is and I
don't think people understand that and I
certainly don't so could you just expand
on that please
Eric sure it is my belief that we have
an idea that the US is the superpower
that won World War II and I claim that
that is not we are not the same country
that won World War II we are so
different from that country agre we are
also different from the superpower that
we were during the Cold War
unfortunately we have incredible
capabilities particularly due to our
technology and we
have some sort of problem in our own
ability to project power that was
manifest let's say in the pull out from
Afghanistan particularly with respect
to clo you know abandoning the base in
the wrong order of
operations the people who carry out
certain who are tasked with carrying out
certain operations are at different
levels of Readiness now the big issue
between' 67 in in Israel in The Six Day
War and the 73 Yom kipur war is that
Israel felt very very vulnerable before
67 and then sort of reveals its military
Brilliance and power uh in 6
7 and then a short six years later it is
caught
unprepared the wrong image of its foes
um you know the Arabs are always weak
they'll always surrender they don't want
want to fight blah blah blah they don't
have the the
wherewithal okay well those beliefs
completely cost Israel in 73 this is a
recapitulation both directly and
indirectly of the 73 situation where we
find out that Israel is not the Israel
that we thought it was and as a result
it's going through a
psychological Sam you don't remember 73
do you I do not no so I remember you
know I remembered a little bit it was it
was totally
shocking right now I think what we found
is is that parts of the IDF are greatly
degraded and Israel was going through
incredibly stupid internal strife over
Netanyahu right before this and you know
I hear about intelligence failure I'm
sorry I it's like I I'm not part of the
modern world it's not an intelligence
failure you you set a reminder that your
grandmother is turning 97 on your
calendar so it comes up two days ahead
of time so you remember to call you
don't set a reminder on the 50th
anniversary of the greatest surprise in
modern times in modern Israel I I just
it's almost to the day it's like people
you know I think Peter teal was the
person who pointed out to me that the
Battle of Vienna you know happen
happened on September 11th or something
like this we should have a reminder on
all of these things having nothing to do
with intelligence this is a complete
screwup and it's reflective of the fact
that and I'm very concerned about this I
don't think the US is the us at thinks
itself to be I don't think that Israel
is the PowerHouse that it thinks itself
to be it may get there in two months it
may be that it's not so degraded that it
can't snap out of
it but I'm very concerned you know
we're mostly seemingly you know uh
troubled by whether or not our our SEAL
Team Six is transgendered enough
um we have to recognize that we have
World responsibilities we have several
politicians who want us to cultic
retreat into ourselves in a multi-polar
thermonuclear world with new biological
capabilities I've been at the top of my
lungs screaming Sam took me to to Sydney
a Australia where I got up on stage and
said we need to be exploding uh rare
thermonuclear weapons above ground so
people remind themselves of how
dangerous the world has become but we're
in some sort of complacency in which we
we think Israel is this Powerhouse but
it isn't and you know it's also the case
that the human intelligence has probably
degraded because operation Magic Carpet
um and the like pulled Jews out of all
of these places that natively spoke
uh all of these uh languages in Muslim
lands so you could pull an you know an
ell Cohen and have an Egyptian Jew
infiltrate the Syrian High command way
back when but how many how many Jews can
you recruit how many Jews are currently
operating secretly inside of Gaza with
access to Hamas Hamas is bragging that
only five people knew the date and
time you know of this attack and so you
know my my concern is is that
Israel is much more vulnerable because
it isn't the state it thinks itself to
be which is exactly where it was in 1973
and it's not a coincidence that they
picked the exact
anniversary yeah well I I certainly
agree with all of those concerns um and
the one thing I actually am confused
about see you raised the concept once
and we haven't talked about it I'm not
I'm not confused about jihadism and I I
can't pretend to be confused about it
but
um anti-Semitism I I find gen confusing
I I why just the the Dynamics of it the
fact that even in the immediate
aftermath of something like this it is
operative in in the places that it's
operative I again at Harvard at Stanford
s are you really confused about that
yeah because Eric actually disagrees
with me on this and I want to hear what
you have to say because we had a private
conversation about it that we didn't get
to finish but isn't this the thing that
all four of us have been talking about
and have been concerned about is
woke call it what do you want ideology
World viiew a set of disconnected
slogans whatever the central core of it
is oppressor oppressed Dynamics and
Jews where do they land on that but but
not in in this Cas I mean like it's oh
no it's the oppressor it's the oppressor
being slain by the oppressed is the
argument right so it makes perfect sense
that youd celebrate that yeah it doesn't
uh well first of all within
anti-Semitism was just as real even in
America when the cremator of aitz were
still smoking right I mean literally you
have anti-semitic speeches on the floor
of the Senate you read David Wyman's
book um the abandonment of the Jews
right just it's just this catalog of of
kind of the ambient anti-Semitism in the
US during the Holocaust and and after
um so it's like I just think the the
durability of this animus whether the
Jews are on top or whether they're
obviously on the bottom I mean literally
whether they're they're they're uh
practically eradicated
um I just find yes I I understand it's
its historical Origins and they they are
actually theological I mean so it is
Christian and Muslim theology that get
that that cashes cashes it out
ultimately but I just don't understand
there there so many people are
anti-semitic and are interested in the
idea that you know that there's some
Jewish conspiracy that's controlling
everything and and the Jews are you know
like if you're if you're very far on the
right the Jews are not white you know so
if you're if a white supremacist the
Jews are not white and therefore they're
uh the object of your bigotry but if you
go far enough left the Jews are extra
white you know extra privileged uh and
therefore um they lose in this in this
victimology game um it's just the fact
that it's so well subscribed whatever
changes on the landscape I find perplex
Thomas has a very good sorry Francis
just this one bit and then you go he has
a very good explanation he has a chapter
in Black rednecks and white liberals
called aru's generic M and he talks
about middlemen minorities all over the
world always finding themselves uh in
this situation because of the role they
fill in society of the jobs that they do
uh being middleman they're
simultaneously misunderstood by the
largest Society and also this this is
the confusion that Kanye had about his
his agents and managers pretty much
pretty much um where is
Kanye this this episode would get a lot
more views let's be honest but but to me
it's anti-semitism comes from a lack of
control in people's lives now if you
look at for instance the farle they
would say the Jews are in control of the
banking system the Jews that's what the
Jews control if you look at the far
right now the the
new uh conspiracy theory is a great
replacement Theory and what is that the
fact that the Jews are in control of
Muslims coming to the the West because
they want to eradicate white people I
mean it's obviously
completely nonsensical but this is what
these people believe but there's there's
so few Jews and so that like even even
in an area where they're massively over
represented right I mean even among
Nobel laurates in physics right there's
still a minority there like it's not
they're not a majority of anything and
so the idea that they're that they that
they're in control it's just it's
moronic but that's what these people
believe and they believe that you know
that this group because that's what a
lot of conspiracy theories come down to
this group are in control whether it's a
world economic Forum whether it's Jewish
people but it's people who feel that
they have no contr they have no control
over their own lives they are powerless
therefore somebody else must have the
power therefore it's Jewish
people gone speaking as a Jew do you
understand it
Eric well better better than
this what a loving
insult not not meant I'm kidding go for
it
please there is a spectrum of
anti-Semitism and we're talking about it
we're talking about the whole rainbow at
the moment
and this sort of mutant
rainbow has very different Origins so
the
reason calling it woke doesn't really
point to the fact that it's
revolutionary
it's violent revolutionary thinking
that's the what's behind
woke the idea
is we have a selling we have a campaign
and our campaign is that oppression
leads to
Poverty so now you've got a real problem
when you've got a very clearly oppressed
group that is not poor because that
breaks the entire
syllogism um that is being used to sign
people up
so the the radical revolutionary left
has to hate Jews because they are the
counter example that gives the lie to
the entire program and so that is
why they have you have to have a a
position on the Jews from the far from
the Revolutionary left do they hate
Japanese Americans as much well it was
say over overseas Chinese uh pares you
know but that's because they're
middleman minorities that was my point
okay was we can come back to this but I
was going to say then on the right you
have a different situation for example
people on the right who are anti I keep
thinking about doing a show called my
friends the anti-semites because I'm
actually in dialogue with many of them
um not to name names and a lot of them
are very supportive in fact of Israel
right now because their issue is who
came up with ethn nationalism that
swedes carrying about
Sweden uh is ethn nationalism F you you
know people have a right to be in their
country without somebody say oh that's
just blood and soil like from the Nazis
so their feeling is how can you have an
a state that is got a Jewish star on its
flag and not bring up ethn nationalism
so these are the people that crowd your
Twitter uh comments with you know for me
but not for the that's their that's
their line so their feeling is hey you
should go defend yourself and get these
killers um and you should go back home
to Israel where you
belong right and so that's totally
different than the leftwing thing but
now the question has to do with um a
word that needs to be taken out of our
vocabulary which is
underrepresented now underrepresented
we's talking about an underrepresented
minority I don't know why somebody's
underrepresented um between
1987 and the start of the Boston
Marathon in
1897 I don't think there were any
Kenyans or Ethiopians who won the Boston
Marathon and then after 1987 it's
basically straight Kenyan Ethiopian
occasionally you know a Japanese guy
um are they are Kenyans and Ethiopians
over represented or the rest of us under
represented well you're holding a
competition that's basically anybody can
start anybody can finish and some people
seem to be better than
others all right now if you look at you
know the so-called JQ which is the
Jewish question why are there so many
Jews and all of these powerful
positions uh if you believe in
proportional representation then Jews
are over represented and so you have to
if you believe in underrepresented
minorities you have to get rid of the
overrepresented minority so these are
all these language traps and language
games and people fear How can there be a
people that look more or less like
they're of European descent who often
have names that don't tell you who they
are like McCormick or something like
that um who are privately subscribed to
some sort of secret
Rome uh in a world in which nothing adds
up so particularly right now
anti-Semitism is always going to get bad
when people can see that they're being
lied to its scale I don't care who's
doing the lying its scale the Jews will
be assumed to be behind it yeah that
that part is mysterious to me I mean
that could just be Legacy code this we
we had the protocols the Elders of Zion
and then that just got grandfathered in
so that so people resort to that but the
idea that that would be the story that
everyone reverts to say more well like
why why the Jews under those conditions
you say you you you said it was just as
though it we could just assume this this
if you look at for example who founded
Facebook and who founded Google right
Tech
Giants
um you've got Jews in both
situations if you imagine okay so our
electronic
communication uh with each other is
largely mediated our ability to search
for example so if I put in American
inventors and only black faces come up
at Google I know that somebody's put
code in there to make it appear that
most of the inventors in American
history are are
black who would do such a thing like
it's such a such an obvious bad faith
thing to do on a search engine and then
of course it's going to be well it's uh
Larry pagee and Sergey Brin you know or
if Mark Zuckerberg doesn't allow a story
to circulate or whatever and so in part
be and by the way you may start to see
this with indian-americans there's this
very quiet uh you know to use the
vernacular of our day uh
indian-americans are having a
moment um and you're suddenly going to
realize that you don't understand what's
going on with the BJP you don't know who
the shivna are you have no idea what
indian-americans care about and suddenly
they're in all these powerful political
positions so when you have a powerful
minority and particularly one that's
visually indistinguishable from
others there's always going to be a fear
that because you have high rank banking
people in media
banking
um universities all of these you know
fantastically uh successful Jewish
populations are always going to be on
the hook for the fact that people can
see that their information is distorted
and why aren't you successful Eric well
you know the the old the old answer I
gave Joe Rogan when he asked me about
why one quarter 1% of the world's
population would get 25% of the physics
noo ures that we cheated physics um but
nobody believes that
you I think one way of answering this
question is I don't know uh I don't know
why 99 of the top 100 chess players uh
in open competition are male um it it
feels like a trap to answer the question
I would say that our culture is very
clear that if we want to survive we have
to do really really well and we have to
contribute back so as a diaspora culture
in part our strategy
is uh o over succeed over contribute to
your host Society otherwise we can't um
make our equation work so in part it's
it's a question of anthropics you're
only asking the supposed
JQ um because they are still Jews after
this many thousand years and the
strategy works and you know just go if
you're in the US for example go look at
who donated the wings of your local
hospitals and tell me what the last
names are and I guarantee you that some
of them are going to be Jewish no matter
where you are so in part um this is how
we live we live by being a net benefit
to the Societies in which we reside and
we drive ourselves incredibly hard
knowing that we're always going to be
fighting anti-Semitism so the example I
was going to give is during coid I
didn't understand that um our families
reaction was use the time in you know
indoors to learn as much as you can push
yourself as hard as you possibly can uh
would be badly received in the outside
world which is like of course you're
doing that because you're in a position
of privilege and you just have this
attitude of you know for F's sake um if
you want to look at a similar culture uh
there's a female comedian named zarag
gag who is explaining sort of the Indian
tiger mom approach to Parenting her own
children you cannot major in in history
you can't major in art uh you're going
to major in computer science this sort
of Drive
to um to Excel and succeed is very very
costly and I understand a culture that
that doesn't push their kids as hard but
to be honest if the Jews are going to
survive they have to compete they have
to do very very well in the competition
and they have to give back and anyone
who attempts to talk about proportional
representation is fundamentally messing
with the Jewish equation for survival if
we cannot compete succeed and give back
uh we have a serious problem as Jews
what about
IQ what about it I have heard the
different groups have different IQs I've
heard the same thing and ashkanazi Jews
I have heard have a higher IQ than the
average you know no offense to that I
think what you really want to say is is
there anything to Jewish genetics and
gosh I would hope so um because
otherwise we don't know anything about
genetics why can I spit in a tube and it
tells me what my belief structure is in
what language I pray on Friday night
it's you know clearly um it's both a uh
genetic group and a belief structure
that have co- trvel um but for IQ I
always find this really
strange IQ is just not that
interesting uh in the upper reaches so I
I'm I'm totally up for believing that
Jews have a genetic Advantage but I
don't think that a few extra IQ points
accounts for the level of creativity and
the level of contribution I think IQ is
really powerful below 100 it's much less
powerful above a 100 uh this is sort of
a something that Nasim taleb uh and I
you know have discussed um the fetish
about the fact that it's
measurable causes this real problem
because it's it's a nightmare indicator
it's good enough to suggest that
something is very real that can be
tracked that has a genetic component but
it's not good enough to explain
creativity and I think that for example
if you talk if I talk to my East Asian
friends a lot of them
are are confused and they say things
like where does Jewish creativity come
from we also are supposed to have very
high IQs and we're still in a leader
follower mode how is it that we get into
this Jewish creativity mode so I I
happen to think that because people are
dissuaded from talking about IQ because
they're dissuaded from talking about
genetics uh they they want to focus on
IQ as if it is intelligence which it is
definitely is not it has it's a
component it's an it's related to
intelligence but it isn't and then you
have this problem which is that
um in some sense what really matters is
the creativity that uh that Co travels
and how much of that is genetic I don't
know but it's not a terrible thing to
say that people are genetically
different and that there are trade-offs
you know that the the Jewish
contribution to the National Basketball
Association has been pretty
meager Eric I blame
anti-Semitism rampant yeah do you think
it's also the fact that Jews have always
tended to be Outsiders and when you're
you're an outsider of a group to a group
you're always looking in which means
that it tends towards being creative
because then what you are doing is
you're reflecting the society in a way
that that people who are a member of the
in group simply cannot you will there's
a lot of people who say comedians tend
to be Outsiders comedians are the ones
who are reflecting what is happening to
the society and Jews and
comedy I mean they got together pretty
well trauma and Jews I mean it's a
perfect combination um I don't think
that works because like Roma would be
Outsiders to society and you know I
don't think you've seen the same sorts
of uh Behavior patterns having taught
the Roma having having spent a lot of
time teaching Roma they are much more
seg they're segregated they're not
really part of society in the way that
Jews are there's also a lot of
creativity in that culture but without
the same you know ins system
accomplishment I think that Jews tend to
be in system they tend to work within
the structures that they find and you
know my wife being from the Jewish
community of India you know I have an
opportunity to see a very different
world about you know
the impact of of let's just say you know
the cisson family or the way that the
parses mirror the Jews inside of an
Indian context so I think that you know
there's I don't know why we're afraid of
talking about genetics and and cognitive
ability I don't know why we're afraid of
talking about culture and cognitive
talking about culture and drive together
but the world is not uniform and there
is a Jewish strategy the great part of
the Jewish strategy is is that most of
it is pretty much open source and if you
want to push your children really really
hard to to survive and if you want to
tell them you've got a dragon with with
fire breathing fire down down the back
of your neck because you've always been
oppressed and you'll never know when you
have to leave very quickly on short
notice uh you can duplicate the Jewish
experience good
luck Sam do you have any thoughts on
this before we move on um please don't
say well so I have I have zero interest
in IQ as I've always said even though
I've I've got a lot of pain for having
ever touched the topic my my my only
interest in in differences in human
intelligence as measured by IQ or
otherwise uh between groups is that we
need to solve the political puzzle you
just mentioned which is why does anyone
think that discovering these dist these
differences would be a political
catastrophe right we we had cuz we know
this is what we should we should go into
the science knowing this I'm not saying
we should look for these differences but
these differences will Ambush us because
in so far as we understand intelligence
or anything else at the level of the
brain or at the level of the genome we
will just you know 23 and me is just
going to tell you that there are these
differences between groups in the
relevant genes say
um so I'm not saying we look for these
things but we're going to be ambushed by
them and we just have to know in advance
that any human trait that is governed by
genetics to whatever degree is going to
be with the moment it becomes measurable
it will be at some different mean value
in different populations however you
define those populations I even Spur's
populations you could take Yankees fans
against Red Sox fans and there there's
it will be a miracle if the hundred
traits you're interested in to inventory
are have the exact same mean level
across those two groups now in many
cases these are just going to be spous
comparisons but in so far as there is
a there has been a a genetic kind of
canalization through throughout human
history where you can look at someone
and and give a pretty good guess that
they're you know they come from
subsaharan Africa or from or from the
Indian subcontinent continent or Japan
or Norway and you can do that you you
have to expect that there are going to
me be mean differences in traits that we
find valuable
and that can't matter I mean the thing
that the thing we we we know must matter
is that we are committed to political
equality in all of our plural
pluralistic secular societies and we
should be and the fact that there's
there's some trait that we could
eventually identify and and measure that
is going to be you know a standard
deviation more or less on average in any
given population that's just um that
can't matter and what we know is that at
the individual
level it it simply it simply can't
matter because knowing that I'm 50%
ashkanazi Jew doesn't tell you anything
about my intelligence right like as an
individual I still have to demonstrate
that and it's just not and I get
absolutely no credit if I'm not if I'm
smart and not a bit smarter I get no
credit for having being in one
population versus another the
interesting thing is we don't have the
Persian question because Persians are
going to test really high we don't have
the Irish and Scottish question we don't
have the overseas Chinese question right
we don't have the parsey question so I
think you have to turn it around and say
look there's a lot of asymmetry in terms
of success of groups mhm and we only
have the Jewish question and I think
that this is what I find absolutely
offensive we only have the Jewish
question in Western Europe but Thomas
Sol's point was that there are Jews
everywhere they're just not Jews they're
somebody else in in Asia it's overseas
Chinese in the Ottoman Empire was it was
Armenians you you can go down the list
right so there are local Jews in every
area they don't all look like you right
that that's really the the point but I
think the broader point with both of
what you're saying and the reason that
we're terrified of these conversations
is that it violates the sacred man
Mantra of our society which is all we're
all equal you know this is this is
embedded in all our conversations this
we're all politically so there's two
Notions of equality here that we we can
be we can conflate political equality
does not at all suggest that every
person is equally talented equally kind
equally smart I mean there just making
equal contributions people don't make
that distinction in their head that's
why Sor even the Communists the the
aphorism of Communism is what from each
according to his abilities to each
according to his needs the idea that we
are somehow Blank Slate equal yeah is
totally new it's it's beyond communism I
don't know how to State that's what I'm
saying it's worse than communism it's
worse than communis worse than communism
yeah it is it is and the idea that that
human beings don't vary in including by
group is just demonstrably not true and
the idea of political equality seems to
me correct me if I'm wrong was invented
to address that that's the whole [__]
point yeah yeah yeah and we know we want
a society that is
fair give and that's completely
independent of the differences between
people like like it's just we we want we
want everyone to have the oper in terms
of our ethical and political commitments
we want everyone to have every
opportunity they can use right and if
there's some people who can't I mean
through no fault of like there there's
someone right now being
born from whatever population with
whatever genetic endowment what whatever
culture surrounding them waiting to
improve their lives with brain damage
based on just a pure accident of what
happened during labor right so what do
we do for that person we you know in a
in a society where we have the bandwidth
to just figure out how good life can be
right where we're not you know where the
bombs aren't falling and we're not we're
not facing some existential threat we
know we want to Marshall our resources
to make life as good as possible for
everyone to the degree that they
can uh have their their hopes and dreams
realized and there there's some very
limited hopes and dreams that we need to
cater to I mean just look at look at
make a you know Make A Wish Foundation
right it's like you got you you have
kids who have Pediatric cancer who've
got a Time Horizon of 6 months what does
a good life look like in that case we
need we we know that success politically
and economically for us in our society
is to have the bandwidth to cater to
that
compassionately um and that's what the
project is and figuring out what the
mean value for IQ is across groups is
not part of that and it's not it's not
an insult to that either but if in our
founding documents we have the idea that
all men are created equal and we know
that at that time women didn't have the
vote and people held slaves I don't
think it's the case
that one part of our soul cries out for
equality at this more beautiful level
and another part of our soul says oh my
gosh these groups are super dangerous we
they cannot accumulate more power right
and that part of our soul we don't
acknowledge that we are we have our
thumb on the scale trying to figure out
who really shouldn't be voting um what
information shouldn't be out in the
public because it will tend to to
Prejudice people and I believe that in
some sense we're just not able to be
honest about our
conflicts um when we stay things like
one man one vote and yet Wyoming gets
two senators and California gets two
senators it's clearly honored in the
breach and we don't make eye contact
with the fact that we are of many Minds
about equality and about uh
accomplishment and achievement and what
constitutes fairness and in all of those
different
circumstances we only feel comfortable
with the part of the conflict that we
can talk about in public without being
uh eviscerated and I I think that we
have to just be honest that we've been
very
uncomfortable about what is the form of
equality that we are really about and I
one of the things I love about the
American project is that our doct ments
were abstract enough that things that
weren't honored initially in the first
instantiation are honored over time
because there wasn't there wasn't an
explicit Clause saying that women and
blacks don't count right and so as a
result of this you know we debated
should only landholders you know be
allowed to vote um the Headroom in the
documents is the thing that we should
embrace and it's one of the reasons why
the 169 project was so dangerous is that
we we happen to have the Good Fortune of
having wonderful documents ments with
Headroom that can mean things that
weren't meant when the when the Republic
was founded um and trying to figure out
how to become those people that we have
never been is part of the most exciting
maybe the most exciting part of the
American project Francis we've got one
more topic we can open up quickly do you
have any thoughts yeah so I want to deal
because I want and I want to discuss
this which is Hope because it's very
easy particularly in the landscape that
we're talking about social media and all
the rest of it to become pessimistic but
let's look at Hope and the Grounds for
Hope are you hopeful Eric as to the
Future as to this is the one I which I
go first give it to Sam and okay well I
did just this morning I read uh a
um Connor uh friedrick dorf I always
forget his last name the Atlantic writer
he wrote a piece today uh which struck a
note of Hope um in this emergency which
I'm not sure I I I certainly hope he's
right so he he said that just as Joan
didan um in one of her books I think it
was The White Album I'm not sure um said
that the Manson Murders were the end of
the the official end of the 60s right
you know August
1969 um all the idealism of the 60s just
completely once you once you have you
know mad Wildey hippies
murdering people you know
killing pregnant starlets um all the
ideal idealism of the 60s just
evaporated right so um his claim
and he's possibly right what happened on
college campuses in response to what
happened in Israel was the end of the
great awokening in his phrasing it's
like like like we all of us are waiting
for the pendulum to swing back from this
this just crazily
eccentric Distortion of ethics and
political intuitions on the far left and
he's uh he's arguing that that Bell just
rang this week and uh I certainly hope
that's correct because the the the
moral not just untenability the just the
the the Abomination we're witnessing
where you have the same people who are
equally exercised over you know
Halloween costumes that that are
cultural approp
appropriation and they're defending what
happened uh in Israel last week it's
um that you know that dissonance I think
is is something we need to not lose
sight of culture-wide and and uh yeah I
mean I think if if that ha if that
happens I think that would be a very
a very good thing I mean it would it
would be a very good thing for speaking
locally for American politics to we have
we have a you know 15 months or so of an
election cycle that many of us worry
could be uh truly ugly and divisive and
to not have a crazy far having a
decreasingly crazy far-left and
Democratic party as a result would be uh
would be a good thing if you ask me just
picking up from the jidan reference if
you if you look at the passage it is The
White Album where she carefully what she
says is is that there was the sense that
someone was going to go too far right so
she's really talking about a period
between 1967 and 1969 it's really only
sort of two or three years when the
60s uh were at that fever pitch and then
it she says that it ends at that
moment um it's one of the most beautiful
essays I've ever read about our time but
I don't think it's accurate I think that
we've been in this probably since the
Russell and Ali dear colleague letter in
2011 it's now
2023 uh this has been going wrong for a
lot longer it's much more deeply
enmeshed in our society I don't know
that the hippies at the free clinic in
San Francisco were akin to the uh
administrators in the uh diversity
equity and inclusion
um substrate that is now in infesting
all of our
universities uh when it comes to
hope to be honest one of the most
hopeful things that happened and I hate
to put it in these terms was the death
of Diane Feinstein and I
don't I'm not dancing on her grave I
didn't particularly have any strong
feelings except for the fact that she
was clearly not able to do her job and
was being propped up by the system and
and so without feeling good about the
fact that someone died um although she
lived a long life there is the sense
that we will never get rid of Nancy
Pelosi we will never get rid of Mitch
McConnell we will never be free of uh
Tweedle Dum and tweetle D in the form of
Biden and Trump and of course demography
is going to have its way with the things
that are blocking progress
um we have had the same people in power
for so long
that we' have given up in effect trying
to make a more hopeful world if you
think about Joe Biden in 1972 he was 29
years old and a senator and he's been
there ever since more or less so hope
comes from the fact that in 10 years
time these people who seem like they
would never leave the stage are going to
be gone
and we have a onetime opportunity to
reorder the world uh around AI around a
different generation of leadership
around the fact that our phones really
matter in a way that are far more
consequential than a piece of technology
would be expected to much morein to the
printing press and there are going to be
a crazy set of opportunities that if we
screw them up we'll probably mean the
end of the world and if we don't screw
them up um we will be exploring the next
systems the successor systems instead of
trying to take a twin fitted sheet uh
and put it on a king-size mattress and
that you know one corner was always
going to pop off that's what we've been
doing for decades now um sooner or later
somebody's going to have to buy or
manufacture a much larger sheet for this
mattress to get it to stay in place and
I think that what what we're seeing is I
was previously hopeful that the post
World War II order would continue to
hold so that the world didn't go
multi-polar with weapons of mass
destruction I think we're about to go
multi-polar and if we survive that then
whatever structures that come after this
it's not going to be capitalism it's not
going to be communism because you can
see the chat PT and its successors are
going to break the capital versus labor
labor uh input this is work that I'm
doing with PM Milani
um we're going to have new economic
systems and it's not going to be the
same players from the 20th century who
are already a quarter of the way through
the
21st preventing progress and it comes
down to well what is it that people in
their 30s through
50s uh are going to re-engineer once the
silent generation and Boomers move on to
better things all right well if you want
to hear the rest of this conversation
head over to locals where we ask Eric
and Sam your questions and continue with
our
own so what you're saying is you're Pro
trumps
yeah the W build the wall exactly you
have recently made the decision not to
speak to some people who disagree with
you why is that I think Brett is one of
them not because they disagree with me
but because I I think they've behaved
unethically I've always thought Brett
was a a extremely ethical person I don't
know how he got so turned
around